next question today's David so in the
end should Michael Bloomberg be allowed
into the Democratic presidential debates
so I've said this before the DNC created
their rules for getting into the debates
and if they want to live by those those
rules they have to die by those rules
unless they simply change them to let
Michael Bloomberg in and they've changed
them and the the big change is that the
early the the donor requirements have
been eliminated for upcoming debates and
indeed Michael Bloomberg may get into
and by the time you even watch this clip
it's possible he may have already
qualified for one of the upcoming
Democratic debates so it depends on how
you ask this question if you ask me is
this a calculated establishment move to
try to give another more centrist
Democrat he's been a lifelong Republican
but okay he's a Democrat now and he's a
centrist Democrat at that the idea is
put someone else in there
who might be able to deny a progressive
the presidency who might be able to
split the delegate counts such that
nobody wins fifty percent plus one
delegates on the first round of voting
at the DNC such that super delegates
then come in and they can pick whoever
they want then if that's the framing
then the answer is no this is another
way that the DNC is putting their thumb
on the scale against progressive
candidates in a Democratic primary if
you simply say to me if someone's
polling third around 14 15 percent
should they be in the debates the answer
is like well yeah they should right I
mean if it when we talk about people
saying continuing to say Andrew yang
never should have cancelled his campaign
we want his voice at the debate we want
more voices at the debates we want to
seize voice despite the fact that she
has not a path to a single delegate if
you want more voices even if you don't
like them right it can't be out of
personal bias it has to really be you
want more voices how do you say the guy
who's polling third nationally right now
shouldn't be in the debates
so I simultaneously recognized that the
entire Bloomberg thing is
people who are desperate to prevent a
progressive from being nominated who
were seeing Biden falter and Budaj edge
maybe become the establishment choice
but he still got issues and Amy
Klobuchar doesn't seem to there is a
desperation for maybe Bloomberg could
come in and pick this entire thing up or
at least deny a progressive the
nomination that's terrible I hate that
if you say someone's in third place
should they be on the stage the answer
is like yeah they should they should be
on the stage and if their ideas are bad
they should be exposed as bad on the
stage so it's that there is not a clear
answer here without being a supporter of
Michael Bloomberg's I don't find there
to be a strong ideological case to say
the guy in third place shouldn't be in
the debates change my mind I'm open to
having my mind changed on this